I have a lot of internet memes but I
think this one is just gonna like follow
me until the 10th you know I have a few
lanes but that's gonna be the kids
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions even hotter wings
and today I'm joined by Tyra Banks she's
a fashion world icon legendary
supermodel TV host business mogul and
she has a new book perfect is boring 10
things by crazy fierce mama taught me
about beauty booty and being a boss Tyra
Banks welcome to the show I like how you
said booty boot hopped it you pop that
pop that booty how are you a spicy food
you're ready oh ok no such a lightweight
really oh my god I can't handle it but I
love this challenge I mean I have my
friends they're like girl you black
right I'm like yeah like well we've race
with spicy food I'm like my granny
didn't make it that spicy all right Tyra
why are you ready to runway walk through
ten scorching hot chicken I love it you
did there I am
[Music]
ooh
oh it smells kind of sweet ain't no
thang belching away oh good I can deal
with that so there are many sides to tie
red we'll get into them all today but I
want to start with Tyra Banks Business
School professor I know that you were
helping to teach a class for Stanford
MBAs called Project you building and
extending your personal brand yes is it
true that you started class by having
all the students take one-minute videos
of themselves yes how do you know that
who told you that
yes I wanted to see what they thought
their personal brands are and so part of
that is them submitting a video of them
talking about themselves and what they
think their personal brands are so that
from that first thing to the last thing
they do it's totally different and they
learn a hell of a lot you know one of
the things about building a personal
brand that's tough is to not look like a
jerk who's building their personal brand
how do you avoid that what's your advice
for that means that the narcissistic
kind of view of it it has to be really
natural it can't be like you're forcing
it at the same time if your brand is
being a jerk then jerk away like lean
into it really ride that ride the jerk
who's running the tip just a lot just
the tip this all sounds strange I grew
up on this one you're familiar quite
[Music]
oh yeah I know this loose our fish
Fridays when I was a kid my mama
bye-bye fried fish then we take
Louisiana hot sauce and ketchup mix it
in a big bowl and then dip the fish in
that so this is taking you back our foam
oh my god I hear like hip-hop no taking
me back been skinned have a Tyra Banks
interview without talking about
America's Next Top Model it's a cable-tv
institution one of the longest-running
most successful reality shows ever when
you think about all the over-the-top
competitions whether it's the treadmill
runway or the bubble ball walk which one
was most fun for you to watch from a
distance I would have to say my models
walking down a building like like this
is the building it is 10 stories high
this is my model on the edge of the
building and she has on a harness and
she's now perpendicular to the building
and she is walking down the building
facing the ground that was wonderful
from afar do you have a favorite guest
judge nicki minaj
she's like you cute and all but you know
I think that the hair should be a little
bigger I really like to her do you get a
kick out of seeing that we were all
rooting for you give all over the
internet or do you kind of wish it would
go away it's everywhere it's never going
anywhere so I have to own it and people
come up to me and they're like please
here's my name my name is Paul now can
you just like substitute the name for
Paul and I'll do it sometimes it depends
on the mood right now it's kind of like
a party trick and then America's Next
Top Model it's a competition which
naturally breeds rivalries but I'm
curious when you look back on your own
career what are the most savage chess
moves that you've ever seen models do to
try to get ahead Oh
I mean I've experienced it myself quite
a lot I remember there was one model I
was about to walk on in the runway and
she was like yeah just crap I hope you
like crazy it felt like it was straight
out of showgirls trying to get in your
head yeah another one I don't know who
did it actually but had these big shoes
that I had to put on and my dresser
dressed me and like and dressed me like
right close to the edge of the runway I
jump on the stairs Willy fast and I
start walking and I realized my
shoelaces are tied together so I had to
sashay like really close like
like but you didn't fall never honey
I've never fallen on the runway
Tyra always ends up on top always on top
this tip and top stuff is just a little
too much and the sexy hot wings oh my
god it's just too hot that's good not
picking it up
I like creeps up mm-hmm there's creepin
mm-hmm it's very TLC I'm showing my age
90s so you know that you've arrived may
become a permanent fixture and rap
lyrics and I'd venture to say that Tyra
Banks is probably the most name-check
supermodel in the history of hip-hop so
with that in mind what I want to do is
bounce some classic Tyra Banks bars off
of you and I'm just curious how they hit
your ear your opinion maybe you'll like
it maybe you don't like it maybe it
leaves it confused and we'll just go
from there just that's all okay all
right so this first one is from Paul
wall it's off fly I got the top steady
drop in like record sales paint change
in colors like Tyra Banks fingernails
oh he's sanding up my nails be changing
my nail color be changing I appreciate
that but look at my nails right now
they're not changing color they're like
so bad so busted he needed to be like I
got the fingernails looking like I'm
living up in jail like a power of banks
close the fingernails as looking like
hail something like that that's what
this looks like
all right so this next one is from
Lauryn Hill it's off keep it tight
chicks tried to model after me like I'm
Tyra Banks want to thank me because my
statements are prodigious styles so
prestigious make a sinner act religious
oh my god wait Lauryn Hill put me in a
rhyme Lauryn Hill put you in a rhyme and
I don't know this it's off the song keep
it tight
this is sacrilegious it's an amazing
song oh my god Lauren that's you don't
understand Lauryn Hill she has songs
like Zion and songs that bring me to
tears so I bow down to you miss Hill I
did not know that you put me in that I
feel like I'm about to faint give me a
pill to make me rise up with this sauce
that's making me blow up my mouth
because it's so hot yeah it was so act
it was not I was in I was in another
could have got another 44 bars
oh my god you know what let's do that
after okay I've one more for you this is
from 2 Chainz it's off Bentley truck
shortie thick small waist fat ass gone
shake money tall Tyra Banks we
everything y'all ain't owe money tall so
he's saying that I got high it's a
double entendre but I'm tall and got
money yeah I like that too Chainz
does he wear 2 Chainz I've come across
some two times one time is wearing 2
Chainz and one time is only wearing one
chain but it was a very big chain so I
it's almost like jeans and isn't he tall
he's very tall and he has money and he
has money and I'm single oh and I got on
one chain I need another one if you
don't have a we we see what you're
putting out there we see you're putting
out there two chains if you're watching
I tire are you ready to move on yes and
before we move on we're going to have a
very special guest joining us at the
table all right we are joined at the
table with Carolyn London who is the
inspiration the foundation for the new
book perfect is boring and you guys have
inspired so many people with this no
punches pulled candid mother-daughter
relationship and true hot ones fashion
we're gonna try to pull some skeletons
out of the clown but first let's see the
wing it's coming up though mm-hmm it was
late sneaky sneaky pete no it's coming
but it's yeah cute right yeah so that
the heat doesn't keep rising that's the
tip there you go the more you know can
you give me a mother-daughter argument
that you guys had while writing the book
oh yeah she messed up all my writing I
would wake up in the middle of the night
and I'd have these magnificent memories
that I wanted to record and I would
write for an hour an hour and a half
beautiful flowery five pages I can see
the prose in my head and then I'd show
it to her the next day I mean I'd be
like this is beautiful these are five
beautiful pages you see that one
sentence right there that is the one
we're going to keep
so then a cuss out proceeded and then
finally whose brilliant idea was that
the attend scorching hot chicken wings
today I'm a bad Tyra i watch his show
and i was like oh my gosh my can we
handle it can we handle it Sean I didn't
even know what your show was it's
alright that's why I appreciate it gonna
turn on my computer and show me what
people were doing and I was like you
want me to do what yeah and then she
started making requests she's like oh my
god that show so good
and she goes and they asked us for milk
she was like but I saw people get ice
cream
I'll need ice cream we did we got you
guys a pint oh oh we need that cuz that
really cools it down yeah very smart
very smart alright you ready to move on
yeah you're amazing mama you did good
hey you got a Tyra you got it
all right Tyra well we every current
segment on our show called explain that
Graham where we do a deep dive on our
guest Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so I'll
bust out the laptop I'll show you the
picture and then you just tell me the
bigger story does that sound good
sure first things first random act of
fierceness with RiRi I was at the
Chateau Marmont Hotel chillin and
Rihanna came in totally glamorous or
just big like kind of coat on and we ran
into each other in the lobby and I was
like you know you my big forehead sister
you know we got to do pictures together
and so we did that photo together and I
told her to really get into it to lean
and like pose and she hit it and we did
another one where we uh showed how
beautiful our foreheads are I was gonna
say you're part of the forehead family
but you're not you're just buzzed well
you'd be able to tell Oh at least yeah
put your hand right where your hair
starts that's a little higher right
there you're my cousin I wouldn't say
you're my forehead brother I want in the
club so bad you're so not like the
velvet rope is kind of like almost come
back in a couple of years all right all
right Thomas awesome Karma's on me
[Music]
different ones burn different parts of
the mouth this burns my throat yeah
let's just burn back there it's by
design all the peppers they hit you
differently so we're really throwing a
lot at you yeah it's now on my throat I
kept I had a sore throat I'd be healed
right now be like I'd be fine on the
rise of Instagram I'm curious what you
just keep talking I'm curious from your
perspective what's the difference
between someone doing Jim selfies with 5
million Instagram followers and then an
angel walking the runway at the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show the one
that's doing this selfies while he's
making a hell of a lot more money these
days so many of these big brands are so
prestigious now like you just want to be
a part of these brands so badly so
they'll have to pay you as much right
back in the day they paid us a hell of a
lot of money and I bought lots of houses
and banks but now if you're like my
social media star they make a lot of
money as social media been good for
modeling is it a good way to discover
talent I discovered Winnie Harlow who
was on America's Next Top Model
scrolling through Instagram there was
this beautiful model African American
girl she had vitiligo it was the most
beautiful patterns on her face and I
just was like I have to find her and I
started asking people on Instagram who
is this who is this and she ended up on
America's Next Top Model and now she's
one of the Teen Choice Awards most
favors well she's a real supermodel now
and I love the fact that models don't
have to like just hope that someone
dressed in black I call it the the
bosses in black choose them and say I
think you're amazing it's like no they
create their own followings and make
themselves stars no barriers to entry
anymore exactly
Dawson's
this one has like things yeah this mmm
this one has like pieces when you can
actually see the hot things like the
whole thing and then when there's a seed
the seed is hotter than the skin you see
that seed right there really getting
into the weeds of the ring over here
that's like not cute
[Music]
so you've been a provocateur when it
comes to addressing how beauty standards
function in society for those of us who
don't have the opportunity to get a tie
over from Ty Ty do you have any advice
for finding your own look let me think
if I were to give you a tie over what
would I do
yeah actually you're good whoa every now
and then I have a model that doesn't
need a tie over I don't think you would
need one Wow you are giving me Justin
Timberlake 2011 oh I don't deserve that
but I'll take it
do you guys feel it it's Justin
Timberlake I'm sure you've heard that
before
well you know I felt very validated when
you said that a bald head was one of
your favorite floss imbued equality yeah
so with well with that in mind can I
show you a couple pics from our season 5
promo spread maybe you can just thumb
through it okay this one is hot you look
a little mysterious you look like you're
about to rob somebody though okay yeah
but it's it's like sexy criminal mm-hmm
right that's nice but I say no mm-hmm um
what is this like I'm like talking to
the last talkin to the sauce this makes
absolutely no sense okay this is a hot
mess a more abstract um this is like
number one thing that a man should not
do in a photo but they do all the time
this thing yeah that this again I feel
like I would not want to be in a dark
alley exactly yeah this one looks like
you're going whew but they caught you
wrong like like Isaac on The Love Boat
yeah yeah yeah
but wrong
this one looks very Shaka brah
like Hawaii kind of hot mess mm-hmm oh
this is good this is good this is good
this is sexy yes I'm seeing a little
baby Tom Hanks in that if somebody ever
told you that yeah first time but I'll
take that see it in the eyes I see Tom
Hanks in the eyes this is hot this is
sexy if you were my new man I would show
this to my friends and my phone say your
cards right Tyra this is a hot mess
okay like it looks like you're playing
the trombone or the tuba or something
right right this isn't I know you say oh
it's hot the hot sauce is imposed we put
some flames we had the whole flame thing
you shouldn't have to think in post
you shouldn't have to explain it should
just be close to should be extra and
wonderful but it should be amazing on
its own flat black oh sweet sweet this
is nice
are you single I am oh ok so let me
explain are you on any dating sites no I
don't do that ok but you should do it
you think so yes but let me explain yeah
yeah yeah when a man has his profile
shot on a dating site and he is not
making eye contact with the camera
his swipes go up the positive swipe
increases his engagement goes higher but
I think it's sad because what is that
saying about women that we don't want
you guys to pay attention oz yeah or
that there's something desirable about a
disconnectors yeah I like I think you're
hot but I think she hotter you don't
mean right but just my advice but if you
did do a dating site thing I would
definitely do him thank you very much
Tyra and I got supermodels for you too
if you want to like date any of those
girls let's let's have a whole powwow
after this ok
[Music]
be careful really looking out for your
tie tack I need some ice cream mama
that's not even food welcome to the show
[Music]
do you still have a crush on Larry David
oh my god I was just talking about this
who's hot my mom likes him too well we
didn't know that we liked him we were
like talking one day and we were like
come buddy no I think it's hot my mom
goes I'm not with any sense right now
Larry David he's hot there's no hot I
know
you got a tire I know that you used to
rewrite commercials when you're a kid
have you ever thought about if you were
to make a curb cameo what your character
might be like I want to build Chrome so
bad I'm not that great with lines
cuz I've hosted a host - no could it be
ourselves and you give you lines people
give you lines it's like Wes
I want you as a host when you had your
talk show did you find that you had more
leeway to go there because they know
that you understand the stakes and
backlash that might be involved mm-hmm I
have my talk show I got in the bed with
Janet Jackson I did all kind of crazy
stuff with me on tray okay do you feel
safe on this talk show not at all
it doesn't stop mm-hmm how do you deal
with it
mind over matter you have some ice cream
you have some milk you guys understand
this is real how are you okay uh-huh
I'm with you okay you and me walking up
the mountain
this next one is mad dog 357 with number
9 plutonium
[Music]
sorry ok I want to trade places with a
cameraman um I would trade places with
you I can't really obviously can't put
that wing in your mouth bill put that
wing in your mouth bill oh good Cheers
oh wait not that one well which one the
number 9 Matt I don't know no bill bill
oh this one yeah okay they're spicy
mm-hmm so bill when did you know that
you were in love with Tyra Banks uh
depend forever come to life no you came
to life life life sighs yes you fall I'm
sorry yes I did
I'm doing live sighs part two is
I think I'm ready okay why am i walking
with my feet hurt you know it's so funny
I saw Kevin Hart do this and he was
really like crying and acting crazy and
I thought he was just doing his Kevin
Hart thing and then it realized well
mm-hmm so in your book you say real
women know when to apologize and it
seems the music career is your biggest
make oppa you're a rap name tie lock ski
mask dog tie leukemic dog does she ever
come out are you saving her for York's
18th birthday you want it right now yeah
I want it right now you want it before
it after the wing I want it right now
okay you wanna beat box me in yeah yo yo
I'm 34 8 but that's okay cuz the rest of
my body is just to shake I'm 5 foot 9 I
look so fine yes all my fellows are so
different when I'm finished with [ __ ]
you might as well just dismiss all the
other female rappers cuz y'all just
appears my eyes so green
they look so keen if I had one look you
know what I'm use my hair so crowning is
always down and on my face there never
is a found that when you enough we will
nothing you better get on your knees and
kiss my hand go to give is ego Tyra
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
my mother told me my Balu B you know
I've never been drunk ever now yeah I
feel heard something about this makes
you it's a weird and your brain goes
somewhere it's trippy oh my mom said she
never raised a quitter Tyra Banks back
from the dead be careful with that bata
here let's switch weights
let's switch Oh gentlemen Cheers Tyra
what a run it's been back from the dead
Tyra Banks on the last dab
it's burning my throat okay so the
reason why I'm not dying right now de
bomb burn that huh huh
squirrels dab is in my back of my throat
so I've got even burn this happening
right now so it's not doubling down on
the burn still hot as hell oh all right
Tyra here we are ten chicken wings down
belly full of hot sauce and just one
more obstacle in the 2008 New York Times
profile you reported to have 275
different smiles at your disposal
ranging from flirting and commercial to
angry but still smiling so to put you to
the test I'm gonna call out each one of
these hot sauces and then you hit me
with the smile for each song hey humble
house Louisiana
Greenmarket sauce hot ones
ham and egg
karma Dawson's to bomb Mad Dog 357 ha
the last death
[Music]
put it in the history books Tyra Banks
on hot ones what a run it's been as much
fun as I've ever had on set and I'm not
just saying that yes you're in dead-ass
serious oh my god now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you Tyra Banks this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
by my book the perfect is boring
give me the book this book is so raw it
is so real we talked about how to win
how to get that money how to make that
cheddar how to make the life better and
how to know when you might have a dream
like being a singer but it ain't the
calling baby this thing no you guys that
is like I think the only way you can
handle this is like if you don't have
the right taste buds or something right
okay wait we got it so this is that's
why yeah yeah yeah yes that always is
like
hey what's going on hot ones fans and
Sean Evans checking in if you enjoyed
the video do us a solid please subscribe
we're not above begging for clout over
here so you know what to do smash that
subscribe button with a sledgehammer who
appreciates you me